I decided I didn't want to waste
you know waste the position that we
found ourselves in you know with wealth
comes enormous responsibility and and
capitalism has enormous faults I'm going
to say this the only system that seems
to work but it also throws up this
enormous wealth tennis players you know
ten tennis players enormous ly wealthy
thousands of tennis players very poor
you know and in a basketball players
football is the same you know right for
our society you've got this extreme
extreme wealth that's great for created
by capitalism so if you're one of those
lucky people who you know who are in
that position where you get that extreme
wealth you know you've just got to make
sure that wealth goes back to society in
some form or another whether it's
creating more jobs or whether it's you
know tackle tackling the problems of the
world that money must not languish in a
you know in a bank account and be
unproductive you can make a big
difference and you know a relatively
small amount of money you can you know
you can make a big difference to a lot
of people's lives so over the years I
think we have continued in that spirit
but we've never really had the resources
to really make a difference and we never
ready you know never already had the
party bills they you know pick up the
phone - you know Clinton or Mandela or
you know whoever in the world and get
straight through and get things done you
know so now I'm in that position and it
would be very sad to waste that position
and you know just to carry on you know
trying to accumulate wealth and more and
more wealth and you know it's important
we have the Virgen machine to generate
the wealth but then it's very important
not not you know it's also very
important for the staff of worker virgin
to know that that wealth is going to be
spent in a constructive way and
and that's what we've had to do